you probably remember majora's mask is
that one weird Legend of Zelda game a
creepy mask a creepier kid wearing a
mask and even creepier happy mask
salesman and some of these seriously
creepiest problems for link to solve oh
and the moon you remember the moon 15
years later Nintendo has beefed it up
for 3ds adding improvements that make it
more palatable for short play times and
a more enjoyable experience overall a
lot of small refinements add up to an
impressive new version of one of the
most enigmatic and beloved Zelda games
following the events of Ocarina of Time
link finds himself in the strange region
of termina Tarina is currently under
intense scrutiny from the moon no
seriously the moon because it's
plummeting towards Earth and will crush
it in three days this is because of
Skull Kid a not entirely human child
using an artifact called Majora's Mask
to summon the world's Doom link must
stop the moon's descent but he has only
72 hours luckily he can use his magic
ocarina to play the song of time and
rewind time allowing him to live those
72 hours again and again like Bill
Murray in Groundhog Day these 72 hours
are spent seeking out items errand
running and dungeon crawling dungeons
can require the entire three days to
complete forcing you to rewind back to
the beginning once you complete them it
really takes a lot of thinking to map
out those 72 hours and how best to use
them this isn't a stroll through Hyrule
that's for sure
while the famous boss battles haven't
changed too much they feel more
manageable than they did in in
attendence 64 original although this
doesn't mean they're easier fights have
been adjusted to prevent you from
exploiting a bosses attack pattern
meaning they won't always do the same
thing with the same regularity it makes
these long fights feel new and
interesting and makes success more
satisfying
the best kind of items to find are masks
masks solve nearly every problem
the blast mask explodes things the great
fairy mask attracts stray fairies
another teaches you how to dance one to
lead small animals another to run faster
and look like a bunny some turn you into
other races like the D goo mask and
Goron mask these help to solve puzzles
and more easily navigate some areas
depending on the skills ascribed to the
mask speaking of making life easier if
you play Majora's Mask 3d on the new
Nintendo 3ds you'll benefit from the
system's extra features the added C
stick lets you change the camera angle
at will so tracking quick moving bosses
in combat and writing Epona are much
easier this makes playing on older 3ds
models feel a little clunky so if you
have to choose the new 3ds is the way to
go for a better experience other small
changes include more save points and a
better song of double-time that lets you
fast forward to it ever hour you choose
within a same-day window but by far the
best changes to the Bombers notebooks
which are more detailed and
comprehensive these books are your
quests log where you keep track of
uncompleted and failed tasks successful
ones and the rumors you've heard about
new ones you can also keep track of the
specific day and time events happen and
let you set alarms for them this is an
amazing addition that makes housekeeping
way more manageable and lets you keep
track of what items you get and when
without having to take written notes
yourself with better ways to manage your
time majora's mask 3d is friendlier in
shorter play times you don't need to sit
down for hours and scribble out your own
notes every time you play and it's a
welcome addition to the handheld's
library it's still the odd mind-bending
classic but with new additions that make
it much more enjoyable and fresh feeling
after so many years